aprender é como a calçada portuguesa a
pedras brancas e pedras negras e se
pensarmos assim como escolher
temos coisas certas e temos escolher -
certas ao longo da nossa vida nós vamos
construir o nosso próprio caminho e cada
pessoa tem o seu próprio caminho e vamos
nos deparar com desafios que nunca nunca
na vida
estaremos à espera de deus e no fundo
vai construir na nossa pessoa e nos vai
tornar mais sábios e mais preto e vamos
cada vez mais acrescenta mais valor à
sociedade
eu acho que hoje em dia minha geração eu
sou mil.no e por isso mesmo nós não
temos tantas oportunidades
nossos familiares mais velhos não tinham
e temos muito mais consolidado em poder
nos desenvolver e acrescentar valor tal
como alan quem dizia a melhor maneira de
prever o futuro é criá-lo
muitas vezes nós ouvimos conversas o que
eu deveria fazer ó qual é a melhor
carreira o que é que definir isso pra
nós millions
é verdadeiramente uma questão nós não
sabemos nós que temos e queremos ouvir
coisas do gênero o futuro é vosso
vocês vão mudar o mundo
vocês vão trazer tecnologia nos vão
permitir servir as pessoas e por isso
mesmo eu achei que o sistema era
fundamental
entrados alguns dos números associados a
este tema há cerca de cinco meses
fui convidado para um workshop na nova
é o único shopping
curiosamente era organizado pela nova
nem mesmas e maior parte da platéia
seria um estudante seria mulher e minha
escolha foi aceitar eu vou lá eu vou
contribuir com a minha opinião masculina
e com a minha visão do que é que do que
é como se está a tornar e como tal
responsabilidade
essa que não fez pensaram que nem como é
que ia preparar um para o workshop e
repassar uma pesquisa encontrei o livro
da chef observar porque atualmente a cia
ou do facebook um cara que possivelmente
não só vai assim iriam que era um homem
mas não é uma mulher que é seu alvo
fácil
isto leva nos a pensar como é que as
mulheres estão a progredir nas
organizações que novas visões estão a
trazer e como estão impactar o mundo
ainda pouco ouvimos falar dos leves e do
empreendedorismo e e como é que novas
revisões nos podem apertar tanto valor
pois bem cada vez mais vamos ter essa
regata na nossa vida e ainda vai ainda
vai porque há muitas organizações que
estão a fazer um esforço tão por atingir
o jack quati ao tanto ouvimos existem
funcionará dentro tem que funcionar para
a organização e não tanto como uma
manobra de marketing e vendas
ao ler o livro
eu já comprei o iron dois dias antes do
workshop mil em 48 horas
ao ler o livro fiquei chocado com alguns
números que fui encontrando
apesar do rival estar muito mais
direcionado para os estados unidos
eu quando fui à procura do livro apenas
de encontrar
veja a versão traduzida esta versão
traduzida trazia alguns números
representavam o nosso mercado aqui em
portugal e fez fiquei chocado ao saber
que 6,3 por cento
é o número representa as mulheres nas
comissões das administrações todas as
empresas presentes nesse 26,3 por cento
deixamos a pensar no que vem quer dizer
6,3 por cento são mulheres que quer
dizer que 93 por cento são homens e será
o facto de termos este equilíbrio em
cargo de direção trazo escolhas para as
nossas empresas de plano os pés na
rodada é uma pergunta ambígua muitos de
vós não descolar da minha opinião mas eu
acho que é importante termos este número
na cabeça da mulher podem acrescentar
nada tanto ou mais valor do que os
homens até porque são muito melhores do
que nós em tantas coisas
se olharmos para este 6,3 por cento
isto em um choque mais se entendendo
isso como se elas chegaram até ao cargo
e se consegue acrescentar assim tanto o
vovô nas empresas que permanecem mês
cara dura e receber o mesmo que os
homens os salários deveriam ser iguais
não é mas isso não significa apesar de
ter sido uma tendência que tem vindo a
melhorar ao longo dos anos
ainda conseguimos ver que em média as
mulheres recebem menos 12,8 por cento no
cruzamento e isto comparando a isso
comprando empresas mercados
são muitas variáveis mas isso é
importante porque eu acredito que o
nosso salário deve ser diretamente
o vovô que chutamos uma empresa isso
minha mulher consegue chutar tanto vigor
com um homem então o salário deve ser
proporcional
apesar de ter 25 anos e estar a acabar
um estrago em engenharia e gestão
industrial
trabalhei em uma startup vinho
quando meu trabalho não era só de mim
meu trabalho estava ligada às operações
da startup e quando trabalhamos em um
ambiente tão pequeno
conseguimos ter noção do muitos aspectos
são fundamentais para dirigir um negócio
estava diretamente o ea nas operações da
estatal ouvir fazem com que tenhamos uma
loja para adquirir o faço em quatro
lojas brasileiro
a nossa equipa no escritório era de
quatro pessoas
estou a prática podemos pensar olha aí
ficava uma loja para cada pessoa e tudo
mas não uma mas uma estátua tem recurso
bastante limitados
tudo tudo aquilo que conseguimos poupar
na operação de uma estrada faz uma
diferença diante
espero uma carta que o assunto na
facturação de 20 mil euros para 200 mil
euros ou seja um aumento de 1000%
e na verdade assim como a receita cresce
os custos também crescem
isto leva nos a tomar decisões são
fundamentais todos os dias em que
precisam isso que eu acerto um animal e
dois não estava certamente preparado
para fazer mas como tal e como equipa já
está eram os dois milênios partilhávamos
alguns valores
isso foi fundamental para que tudo
corresse na mesma forma
vamos apresentar aqui alguns números são
e que representam as prioridades 2009
hoje em dia
em primeiro lugar temos o uruguai pé mas
este conceito para nós quer dizer uma
coisa pra vocês querem dizer outra
totalmente diferente
temos também essa oportunidade e os
afilhados pode ser a oportunidade de
crescimento podem ser apanhados
trabalhar em projectos internacionais
o projeto nacionais para quem gosta
tanto trabalhar aqui em portugal o que é
ótimo
temos um tempo fantástico tem uma
cozinha muito muito superior é tantos
países do mundo sempre o seu lugar é
flexibilizado
hoje em dia e também característica da
minha geração nós tendemos a ser mais
flexíveis em quarto lugar com 900 temos
o impacto do que o impacto e por outro
têm temos a produção que era um tema que
esteve em banho maria durante alguns
anos
infelizmente vai à tona e é um tema
muito falava hoje em dia como estava a
falar warcraft da ans apresentou a
quarta da lan para nós millennials
apresenta uma coisa pra vocês que são de
outras gerações que apresentou
totalmente diferente
eu acho que cada vez mais as empresas
têm de ouvir as pessoas que vão entrando
nas agressões a pouco e pouco
segundo um estudo de uma seguradora ao
ego
muitos deverão acontecer em 2025 75 102
pessoas trabalham nas organizações
similares aos 75 por cento
quer dizer três em cada quatro pessoas
está chocando o mundo várias
oportunidades muitos nós pensamos a
gente para termos melhores oportunidades
temos seguido 50 anos
porque achamos que eu infelizmente não
vamos surgir novas oportunidades
o sargento é preciso ter uma análise
muito mais crítica e perceber de onde é
que surgem as oportunidades campos
apropriados
enfim nós podemos trabalhar para que o
xoom é um pedido incomum
dizemos a tivesse sorte há tantas
pessoas dizem ah só está a trabalho
a sorte no fundo advém de acontecimentos
que provar em todo um trabalho está por
trás de muitas vezes as pessoas não
olham pra esse trabalho todo o seu lugar
não estava a falar de flexibilidade que
é isso foi assegurado há pessoas que
trabalham melhor amanhã como eu a pessoa
que trabalha muito
a noite estava a ler um estudo de
pessoas que trabalham em marketing e
precisam mesmo de muita criatividade e
dizem que a noite conseguem trabalhar
muito melhor porque existe - ruivo no
nosso mercado
estamos muito mais focados naquilo que
estamos a criar
é preciso termos a abertura já
conseguimos perceber isto
em quarto lugar o impacto que isso um
pacto
muitas vezes ouvimos mil e mails de zero
eu não estou a ter um impacto na
organização estava à espera mas não é
verdade que aqui estamos
muitas vezes o meu é meu povo não teria
efetivamente noção de como é que a viver
mas pra ter responsabilidade com empresa
definir métricas de tornar o impacto
mais tangível possível
nós tivemos métricas e objetivos ao
longo do percurso ficamos com uma noção
muito mais correta do que estamos a
fazer e do vovô que estamos aqui sentar
nas organizações e por último
a produção que era um tema que hoje em
dia faz com que nós mil e nilza possamos
optar entre uma empresa onde temos um
caminho mais também vá mas acabamos por
não mexer tanto outra empresa onde
querem mais volátil mas podemos crescer
muito
estamos bem como as ações
nós conseguimos assumir o risco e se
quiser realmente gostei bastante
vamos passar por uma startup a qualquer
momento
estamos aqui operar em portugal estamos
a entrar na outra parte do mundo e hoje
em dia
decisões dependem de cada pessoa
não há uma decisão correta o melhor há
muitas decisões corretas mas todas são
paulo emerson jéci em 2018
nós olhamos muito para trás mas o que
interessa não é só um já passou mas sim
o que se vai passar a seguir o nosso
caminho como estava a dizer que nós e
das organizações tanto nós mil e mails
como empresas vamos ter de nos adaptar
esta você olhar
nós não conhecemos nós falamos sobre o
futuro e temos teorias como é que vai
ser o futuro mas nós não sabemos
tal como a calçada portuguesa nas
passadas têm de ser adaptadas para
formar estes padrões nós também temos
nos adaptar e é fundamental nós
cultivaram esta esta ideia nas pessoas
não sendo formadas há pouco um pouco
porque vai passar para as empresas eco
os mil e nós querem adaptar à função é
que essas criaturas e referendos que
chegam ao mercado
acham que têm razão em tudo
o desafio luso falou em como pessoas que
conheçam seja mais novas e de ação o que
elas têm para dizer
apesar do pessoas enfim mais velhas que
tenham 10 15 20 anos de presença no
mercado saibam tanto sobre o mercado e
como é que os negócios funcionam as
pessoas mais novas podem trazer algo
mais em vôos nesta mudança porque esta
mudança irá ter um impacto enorme na
vida todos nós
qual é que vai ser a nossa escolha
obrigada
[Aplausos]